massive day in my career got a woge bomb
pretty fired up big shout out to AJ and
Greg genske on the Vayner sports team
and a humongous welcome welcome to Bay
Frasier the new president CEO of Vayner
basketball inside of Vayner Sports
Bay Carmelo and the whole crew joining
the Vayner Sports crew welcome I'm
humbled and for all the basketball
players and the ones that are emerging
we're really excited to be in the game
obviously one of my favorite sports in
the world and the fact that now Vayner
Sports is in the basketball game is
super humbling especially when I think
about the impact that bay and mellow
have had on the sport over the last two
decades AJ and I and the rest of Vayner
sports team is massively humbled to be
teaming up on this Venture and I'm just
damn excited specialist playoff
basketball there's a bunch of upsets
this weekend the Knicks about to take
Cleveland down Vader Sports is about to
take it down super fired up inner Sports
basketball is here Bose bomb